[Música]
hace unos 15 años yo ya estaba ha
recibido de biotecnólogos había cursado
varias materias relacionadas con
enfermedades virología inmunología
microbiología y de repente me surge la
oportunidad de hacer un doctorado en
nanotecnología aplicada a la salud que
es a lo que me dedico todavía hoy en día
yo trabajo con estructuras que son
aproximadamente un millón de veces más
pequeñas que el milímetro s que teníamos
en la regla que usábamos en el colegio
por medio de estas estructuras nosotros
logramos conducir medicamentos por
dentro del cuerpo de manera tal de
maximizar su eficacia y reducir sus
efectos adversos para tener una
dimensión de lo abrumadoramente pequeña
que es la nanoescala pensemos por un
instante en un arco de fútbol mide
aproximadamente un poquito más de 7
metros de ancho
en este momento la humanidad cuenta con
aproximadamente unos 7 mil millones de
personas esto quiere decir que si cada
persona me diera un nanómetro podríamos
alinear a toda la humanidad entera abajo
de un único arco de fútbol
volviendo ese día en que decido
presentarme al doctorado la que en ese
entonces sería mi directora de tesis me
propone un tema de trabajo leishmaniasis
yo no tenía idea de qué se trataba esa
enfermedad
me vine acá tampoco a describirla
académicamente ahora así que me puse a
estudiar un poco y ahí me enteré de que
se trataba de una enfermedad bastante
extendida a nivel mundial que era
endémica en mi propio país y algunas
cosas más que voy a contarles en este
rato para intentar transmitirles la idea
que empezó a resonar en mi cabeza a
partir de este caso
la leishmaniasis se caracteriza bien por
primera vez a principios del siglo 20
cuando el doctor leishman precisamente
identifica al parásito que la causa este
parásito entra al cuerpo a través de la
picadura un insecto parecido a un
mosquito y la enfermedad se puede
presentar en dos variantes una que si no
se trata rápidamente puede ser mortal y
otra que en principio es de figurante
ataca la piel lo que llamamos mucosas
labios interior de la nariz hasta el
punto que en algún momento la llamaron
la lepra blanca e inclusive y una vez
que aparecen estas heridas lógicamente
pueden infectarse y entonces ahí aparece
también el riesgo de vida
en 1912 muy poco después del
descubrimiento del agente causal se
propone un primer tratamiento para esta
enfermedad basado en unos compuestos
llamados antimonio les pentavalentes
unos compuestos de antimonio un elemento
químico que hasta ese entonces sólo
tenía lugar en la medicina como
provocador de vómitos
los efectos colaterales que empezaron a
registrarse eran bastante severos además
de que no se aseguraba la curación total
ni que la enfermedad reapareciera
después de un tiempo esto puede parecer
lógico si pensamos que muy rápido en
pocos años con la tecnología de esa
época los conocimientos en la época
habían logrado proponer un primer
tratamiento pero el caso es que hoy en
día más de 100 años después el
tratamiento de primera línea para la
leishmaniasis sigue consistiendo en
inyecciones de estos compuestos de
antimonio
porque este sigue siendo la primera
línea de estrategia terapéutica contra
la leishmaniasis la respuesta es que los
afectados por esta enfermedad por lo
general son pobres pobres de áfrica de
la india de afganistán de zonas rurales
empobrecidas de brasil de colombia y de
la argentina
en la argentina la enfermedad es
endémica en su variedad cutánea en el
norte del país y las personas que están
expuestas a ella tienen la mala suerte
de además de ser pobres ser pocas
volvamos por un minuto a 1912 todavía no
había nacido la mayoría de los actores
que para todos nosotros son de otra
época no había nacido vive en la isla de
lo que el viento se llevó' y burt
lancaster no habían nacido otras
personalidades como jonas alt
edith piaf no había nacido aníbal troilo
todavía no había comenzado la primera
guerra mundial estaba digo búfalo bill
estaba vivo jorge newbery en rusia
lógicamente estaban los zares existía el
imperio otomano
en cuanto a la tecnología todavía no
podíamos ni siquiera sintonizar
estaciones de radio
106 años después el mundo es otro
apareció la televisión la birome el
nylon la computadora el láser los viajes
al espacio en los años 50 ya se había
descubierto la estructura del adn y para
el 2001 ya estaba secuenciado el genoma
humano entero
en materia de salud entre miles de
avances aparecieron los trasplantes los
órganos artificiales la fecundación in
vitro nos hacemos comúnmente resonancias
magnéticas tomografías computadas
ecografías 3d 4d pero el tratamiento
para la leishmaniasis sigue siendo el
mismo
algunos plantean que la ciencia puede
ser impulsada únicamente por el sector
privado porque el mercado es capaz de
regular la producción científica
orientando la de manera tal que
satisfaga todas las necesidades de la
sociedad pero en este ejemplo y créame
que muchos otros también si el mercado
no fue capaz en 100 años de generar una
nueva solución para los afectados por la
leishmaniasis porque tendríamos que
suponer que va a hacerlo algún día
y hasta cuando lo esperamos hasta el
2000 118
ahora yo estoy diciendo que todo lo que
vamos a hacer los científicos que
trabajamos en el estado va a funcionar
directamente no necesariamente de hecho
aproximadamente uno de cada diez mil
compuestos que empiezan a estudiarse con
el fin de lograr un nuevo tratamiento
terminan convertidos en un medicamento y
esto no es porque trabajemos a prueba y
error al azar sino estaríamos hablando
un número todavía muchísimo menor
lo que tenemos que comprender a partir
de esto es que si tenemos que encontrar
una aguja en un pajar va a ser mucho más
fácil que lo logremos si ponemos más
expertos en encontrar agujas a buscarlo
y no menos
qué es esa postura ese enojo utilitario
esa indignación de silla de que la aguja
aparezca como sea incluso con menos
recursos porque al final lo estamos
pagando todos
y de la mano de esos clamores aparecen
otros los que sostienen que hay que
apoyar únicamente a la ciencia que
persigue una finalidad urgente o bien
aquella que rápidamente puede verse
transformada en un invento que se pueda
fabricar producir patentar y vender y a
esto lo denominan ciencia útil no hay
ciencia útil como una categoría parte de
un resto que en esa lógica deberíamos
considerar inútil
cada tipo de ciencia es necesaria y
necesita que la defendamos porque su
defensa nos hace más ciudadanas y
ciudadanos la ciencia nos permite
comprender y mejorar el mundo que nos
rodea cada una desde su campo de estudio
la ciencia social la ciencia básica la
ciencia aplicada la tecnología que
hacemos en algún producto estrella del
mercado alguna multinacional algo
tecnológico acaso no a brevan de la
sociología para conocer mejor el perfil
de sus consumidores no piensan en el
marketing no hacen encuestas porque
nosotros habríamos de descartar a la
ciencia social
veamos
cómo funciona este tratamiento sugerido
en 1912 se trata de un régimen de
inyecciones muy dolorosas aplicadas
todos los días durante 30 días seguidos
pensemos ahora en el contexto de la
persona que tiene que ir a aplicarse ese
tratamiento y que quizás vive en un
entorno rural y tiene que ir a caballo
hasta el centro de salud donde tienen el
medicamento y dónde está el personal que
sabe aplicarlo día tras día cada día con
más dolor de hecho muchas veces las
inyecciones se terminan aplicando en las
pantorrillas porque en los glúteos ya no
puede soportar más pinchazos esa persona
a todo esto empiezan a aparecer los
efectos colaterales
alteraciones del ritmo cardíaco falla de
los riñones inflamación del páncreas
anemia
picazón vómitos
póngase por un instante en los zapatos
de esa persona que está recibiendo ese
tratamiento y piensa en si le seduce el
panorama
quizás ya lo van adivinando muchos
abandonan el tratamiento otras personas
apenas sienten los primeros síntomas no
quieren saber nada con comenzarlo
siquiera
hay una variante del tratamiento que
tiene menos efectos colaterales y mayor
eficacia pero ese tratamiento es
muchísimo más caro
existen también los llamados
tratamientos de segunda línea que han
surgido gracias a la investigación
promovida por el estado en la india
donde esta enfermedad tiene muchísimos
afectados
hay que seguir investigando
quienes investigan si hacen una búsqueda
en internet se van a encontrar con un
puñado de grupos de distintas partes de
la argentina que trabajan buscando
nuevas alternativas para lograr la
curación de la leishmaniasis
todos estos grupos pertenecen a
instituciones del sector público y es
lógico que sea así porque no se trata
solamente de que uno entre miles de
compuestos es el que va a servir y que
va a terminar convertido en ese
medicamento que vamos a poder conseguir
en la farmacia sino que también el
tiempo juega un importante rol en todo
este juego para que ese compuesto que
tuvo éxito entre los miles que se
descartaron llegue a estar convertido en
un medicamento
se necesitan cumplir muchas etapas que
duran en total unos 10 años pruebas
desarrollos autorizaciones completamente
necesarios es ese ese periodo
a un laboratorio privado puede seducirle
y convenirle
y comercializar fabricar un producto que
ya está desarrollado y probado pero
créanme que ninguno va a destinar
durante 10 años a sus mejores recursos
profesionales a trabajar en un tema que
si llegan a tener suerte y dan con ese
compuesto tiene como público potencial a
un número limitado de personas con
recursos limitados
en el exterior la investigación recibe
apoyo del estado incluso cuando ésta
ocurre en universidades privadas sobre
todo en países que tienen el sistema
científico organizado de esa manera pero
créanme que el involucramiento del
estado
a través de importantes financiamientos
siempre prevalece
a las personas que hacemos ciencia nos
apasionan los desafíos y muchas y muchos
de nosotros encontramos en esos desafíos
una manera fantástica de que ese derecho
a la educación del que supimos gozar y
que nos formó como profesionales tenga
una continuidad evolutiva en este nuevo
rol en el que podemos generar
conocimiento y aportar soluciones que
benefician a la sociedad en su conjunto
y es ahí donde se articulan todas las
facetas de la ciencia y donde más si
necesitamos defender su presencia a
través del estado
necesitamos al grupo que hace ciencia
aplicada para que siga investigando
lograr un nuevo tratamiento una vacuna
contra una enfermedad como por ejemplo
la leishmaniasis necesitamos también al
grupo que hace ciencia básica que es el
que va a haber descubierto que hay un
compuesto que en tales condiciones hace
tal cosa y que no tenían ni idea de para
qué podría servir eso pero ahora el otro
grupo le encontró la aplicación y
necesitamos a los científicos sociales
que son los que tienen las herramientas
que van a permitir articular esto que
ocurre en un tubo de ensayo con la
realidad de esas personas que van a
hacer las destinatarias del tratamiento
imagínense un divorcio entre la ciencia
natural y la ciencia social no sirve
nada más que pensemos lo que ocurre
dentro del tubo hay que pensar que
realmente ese tratamiento vaya a ser
efectivo para esa gente como lo vamos a
hacer
conociendo sus contextos que hacemos
vamos a desarrollar una nueva app para
el celular de esa persona que tiene que
recorrer unos cuantos kilómetros a
caballo o tenemos que pensar en diseñar
nuevas estrategias para comunicárselo
saben que tampoco creo que sea menor el
hecho de que seamos argentinas y
argentinos los que nos ocupemos de
problemas que ocurren en nuestra región
porque creo que quizás podemos estar
mucho mejor preparados que nadie para
entenderlos en mi primer viaje académico
a una universidad europea de un país muy
rico de repente se hacen las 6 de la
tarde y veo que se vacía todo entonces
pregunto y el turno noche no no hay
turno noche me dicen eso pregunto pero y
la gente que trabaja como hace para
venir a estudiar y ahí empezó una charla
entre dos mundos que no podían inter
comprenderse me decían pero cómo va a
trabajar si estudia sí trabaja es porque
ya estudió antes y yo decía no pero si
es la única persona que tiene trabajo en
la casa en ese momento si los padres
alcanza invención pero que son padres o
animales que lo van a mandar a trabajar
cuando está estudiando
claro ellos no podían comprender que yo
venía a hacer la carrera de los 90
trabajando y que muchos y muchos de mis
compañeros también trabajaban y quizás
eran en ese momento en ese contexto de
crisis la única persona de toda la casa
que tenía un trabajo estable y yo no
podía entender que no me estaban
hablando desde una postura de
discriminación clasista sino que
realmente allí todo aquel que quería ir
a estudiar podía hacerlo sin tener que
trabajar entonces volviendo al tema que
nos atañe como no vamos a aprovechar los
recursos humanos que formamos en nuestra
universidad en todas las distintas áreas
para conformar equipos
interdisciplinarios que puedan abordar y
entender nuestros problemas mejor que
nadie
tenemos la suerte de contar con un
sistema nacional de ciencia y tecnología
que tiene un posicionamiento regional
créanme de excelencia pero nos falta
tomar más conciencia de ello y que la
defensa de la ciencia nos empodera nos
hace más ciudadanas y ciudadanos
defender la ciencia es una cuestión de
ciudadanía la ciencia necesita de la
presencia del estado y no puede dejarse
librada únicamente al sector privado
esto que digo puede perfectamente
trascender todas bandería política toda
ideología así sea que prefiramos un
estado más grande o un estado mínimo así
sea que confiemos en el mercado o que le
tengamos todos los resquemores así nos
guste la interacción entre la
universidad y la empresa o tengamos
desconfianza de ella
nuestra ciencia viene a llenar un gran
número de funciones que nadie más que el
conjunto de toda la sociedad a través de
la acción representativa conferida al
estado va a poder garantizar muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]